we have a major follow-up this morning
to a story our david begno reported last
week it's about the case of vincent
simmons who was convicted of attempted
aggravated rape in louisiana back in
1977. you may remember david spoke to
his alleged victims who were 14 years
old at the time and are in their 50s now
they maintain he is guilty but he says
he's innocent and he's been fighting to
clear his name for decades this
afternoon simmons will find out whether
he's entitled to a new trial new
evidence discovered by cbs news could
play a role in the case david begno is
our lead national correspondent and he
is outside the courthouse in marksville
louisiana david good morning
vlad good morning to you listen vincent
simmons has tried at least 16 times to
get a new trial and he may be on the
verge of doing just that today there are
bits of information that were never
heard by the jury which vincent has been
trying for the last 30 years to get a
new judge to hear and say you know what
the jury should have heard that you
didn't get a fair trial so i'm going to
grant you a fair trial among that
evidence is the following when the twins
who were 14 at the time were examined by
a doctor there was no conclusion of
sexual assault that was found by the
doctor also one of the twins that was 14
that said she was raped
was found to be aversion after she
claims that she was raped also when the
girls first went to speak with the
sheriff and the sheriff said tell me
what happened and tell me who did this
to you they couldn't identify their
attacker in fact they told the sheriff
that he's a black man and the sheriff
said well tell me more and they said
well all black people look alike and
then they went on to say all n words
look alike that testimony which many
experts believe could have been damning
at trial was never heard by the jury and
was never known to the defense according
to one of the defense attorneys who is
still alive
speaking of defense attorneys i spoke
with vincent simmons defense attorney
justin bonus and i asked him what is
vincent's state of mind this morning
he's
happy and thankful
and praying
but he doesn't know what's going to
happen the fact that he's not angry
that's the thing about vincent is if i
was vincent i'd be angry he's not angry
he forgives them
because he knows vengeance isn't his
the twin sisters karen and sharon
sanders will be in the courtroom today
this is the first time since the 1977
trial that they have actually gone to a
court hearing for simmons
they insist they are victims and that
simmons is guilty
and so david what do you expect will
happen today
look vlad according to our reporting in
our sources we expect there is a strong
likelihood that judge bill bennett is
going to declare a new trial and if he
does that we can report this morning
that it is likely that the district
attorney charlie riddle will stand
before the judge and the court and
announce that he is not going to retry
vincent simmons number one our reporting
is the d.a believes he could
lose the case and also he believes that
if he were to retry simmons
he couldn't get more than 40 or so years
in prison so he believes
essentially it's okay for him to walk
out after 44 years benson simmons is set
to turn 70 on thursday
we will be watching david begne thank
you as always my friend